really sad story coming out of the
UK it seems these stories come out of
the UK every six months now there's a
baby who is very very
ill uh who is an eight-month-old little
baby who has been granted Italian
citizenship and admission to a Vatican
hospital because the parents don't want
to kill the baby they want to continue
treatment for their precious beloved
child and the UK government said say no
we're going to kill that baby no it's
it's pointless it's expensive to keep
the baby alive it's pointless you know
it's just going to the baby's just going
to die at some point so let's just kill
the baby
now and this is the baby Indie Gregory
the parents say no no that's
awful and prime minister Georgia Maloney
in Italy says okay we're going to Grant
the baby Italian citizenship so that the
baby has a right to come to
Italy the Vatican the holy C says we're
going to Grant the baby admission
to Bambino Jesu hospital so that we can
treat the baby you in the UK don't want
to treat the baby we will treat the baby
just bring the baby over here the UK
judge says Nope kill the
kid means the UK is now essentially
executing an Italian
citizen against the wishes of Italy up
to an including the Prime
Minister more to the point the
the uh UK government is executing a baby
against the wishes of the Pope against
the wishes of the Pope and the baby's
parents it's just awful it's just
absolutely evil and the and the hardest
part
here other than the death and sadness
and grief the hardest part politically
is that the judge probably doesn't know
the judge probably doesn't realize how
bad this is there are a lot a lot of
liberals probably don't realize how bad
this is because in their mind what
they're saying is look this eight-month
old baby terminally ill baby the baby's
not going to survive very long anyway so
like what's the point you're just
wasting money and the baby might feel
some pain maybe and pain is the worst
thing in the world and suffering is the
greatest evil ever and the whole point
of life is to just feel pleasure and and
and if you can't just live forever then
you might as well just die and be killed
there are a lot of people who think that
consciously or unconsciously and there
are so many any
false philosophical anthropological and
Theological premises just wrapped up in
those flippant statements and those
those glib
intuitions but people are not conscious
of that that is the consequence of a
liberal culture right now go to
genucell.com
wle can you believe that Thanksgiving is
just two weeks away Thanksgiving when we
celebrate the arrival of the Mayflower
here in the United States just in time
for the holidays jell is offering their
best sale of the year right now you can
get 77% off Jus cell's most popular
package which now includes Jus cell 3
their newest under eye treatment gen
cell 3 will have you looking 10 15 even
20 years younger it uses advanced
technology to deliver complex vitamins
and minerals directly to your face for
instant hydration say goodbye to Fine
Lines crows feet undry bags and dark
spots the genu cell experience is like
no other but do not just take my word
for it genus cell will have you looking
and feeling your absolute best
guaranteed or your money back
no questions asked our talent manager
Tessa loves genus cell under eye cream
we have the new genus cell 3 product on
the way so she can add this to her skin
care routine you deserve to look and
feel your best this holiday season go to
jas.com
kwes get this incredible holiday
discount for 77% off their most popular
package this includes the genus L3 and
Dark Spot Corrector get results in 12
hours or less the immediate effects are
included for free fre Jus cell.com for
70% off plus free priority shipping Jus
cell.com
today I totally understand how the UK
judge came to that conclusion well he's
going to die anyway might as well be now
yeah well you're going to die anyway
judge should we kill you now I'm going
to die someday should we just kill me
now well the boy's going to feel pain
yeah you feel pain don't you should we
kill you the next time you feel pain so
you don't feel pain anymore well no come
on you know it's just the it's just a
what well you know the baby's going to
die soon yeah maybe you might die soon
you might walk across the street get hit
by a
bus well you know it's just it's very
expensive oh okay well when I think
about all the money that we waste that
we waste in our country in the UK
everywhere money that we waste on stupid
consumer goods or
misguided Social Services quote unquote
that actually end up hurting people when
I think about the money that we waste on
just on the on the
surgeries which is completely
Preposterous doesn't achieve a thing
doesn't help these people feel better is
not in align in alignment with reality
only harms people violates the
hypocritic oath but it's extremely
expensive we waste a ton of money on
that so-called medical intervention but
we can't spend a little extra money to
keep this baby alive a few more days you
won't even let the baby go seek
treatment
elsewhere that's the consequence of a
liberal
religion of a liberal it's not a
religion know religion is a habit of
virtue that inclines the will to give to
God what he deserves it's it's it's a
false imitation of a religion it's an
ideology
and in as much as a country loses its
religion it's going to fall into this
stuff because people act with prejudice
necessarily people don't just
consciously think about every single
thing they're going to do should I have
pancakes or waffles this morning well
let me
examine the benefits and costs of each
let me write a long essay comparing the
pros and cons let me consider the
ingredients and what that will mean no
no one you just I don't know say I don't
know I guess we'll eat pancakes today we
eat pancakes on Tuesdays that's what
we're going to do well people have the
same habitual uh behaviors and
prejudices when it comes to moral
calculation so you never you could pass
a law that would be a good start to say
no don't kill babies in the UK or
elsewhere but ultimately Tim Scott is
right it it's the moment of the debate
that went totally un almost totally
unnoticed but it's probably the best
part of that debate last night when Tim
Scott said look our country just is
Christian our country is Christian or
it's not our country it'll be a
different country there are plenty of
countries that are not Christian and
it'll just be like one of those but if
we want our country even if you're not
Christian even if you don't think you're
Christian or you don't consciously
believe in this stuff if you like the
way our country has been in the past up
until the
present you can't throw out the
animating spirit that that animates the
country as the soul animates the body
man what a great clip that was now hey
hey hey hey hey hold up ring that Bell
subscribe to the Michael NS podcast see
you next time